when gym launch took the entire gym
Market by storm here's how it actually
happened everybody at the time was
running free trials they could only
spend up to X because cash flow because
they had to give 30 days away free and
then spend the money on marketing and
sales to acquire the customers they're
negative for the first 30 days and get a
third of those people to then roll into
a membership at 99 bucks a month well it
would take them three months to recoup
that initial cost we were able to take
over that Marketplace by simply changing
the acquisition model what we did was we
had a program on the front end that we
charged for up front five or six hundred
dollars and our cost to a Car customer
was one or two hundred dollars we would
make back the cost to hire that customer
and the next customer with the 400 left
over we were able to fill gyms to full
capacity in a month without them having
to front the money because they didn't
have the money to front so even if they
had a thousand dollars a start we'd make
more than a thousand dollars back in the
first few days and then we could
reinvest that to get even more people
because the people who are competing
against our gyms could only spend up to
twenty dollars a lead and we could spend
up to a hundred dollars a lead we could
out-compete them even if they had better
ads than us we had a better business if
you can compress the payback period in
that first 30 days you win